BIDEN'S PRIORITY LIST.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
KATELYN COLLINS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE, THANK YOU.
>>> NOW TO THIS.
A FEDERAL JUDGE NAMED AN
INDEPENDENT SPECIAL MASTER TO
REVIEW THE DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
IS SENIOR JUDGE PUT FORWARD BY
THE TRUMP TEAM AND ENDORSE BD I
THE DOJ.
HE WILL RECEIVE THE
INVESTIGATION AND FILTER THROUGH
THE DOCUMENTS.
>> IT PAUSES THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO THE MATERIALS
TAKEN FROM TRUMP'S FLORIDA HOME.
ELI HOENIG IS HERE TO EXPLAIN.
>> WE FINALLY KNOW EXACTLY HOW
THIS SPECIAL MASTER PROCESS WILL
PLAY OUT.
FBI SEIZED ABOUT IS 11,000
DOCUMENTS FROM MAR-A-LAGO LAST
MONTH.
THOSE DOCUMENTS WILL FILTER
THROUGH THE PARTIES AND THEN THE
SPECIAL MASTER.
IT IS SENIOR JUDGE RAYMOND
DREARY.
SHE WAS PUT ON THE BENCH BY
RONALD REAGAN AND TRANSCENDS
POLITICS PARTISANSHIP AND WILL
TAKE OUT DOCUMENTS COVERED BY
PRIVILEGE AND THIS THE DOCUMENTS
GO TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
IN A RULING BUT THE JUDGE
PRESIDING OVER THE CASE GIVING
DONALD TRUMP'S TEAM ALMOST
EVERYTHING THEY ASKED FOR AND
GAVE DOJ NEXT TO NOTHING THEY
WANTED.
THE JUDGE RULED THAT THE SPECIAL
MASTER CAN REVIEW ALL DOCUMENTS
INCLUDING CLASSIFIED FOR
PRIVILEGE.
DOJ DIDN'T WANT THE SPECIAL
MASTER LOOKING AT THAT.
DONALD TRUMP HAS TO FOOT THE
BILL.
TRUMP SAID SPLIT IT.
THE JUDGE SAID YOU WILL PAY.
AND SET A TARGET COMPLETION DATE
OF NOVEMBER 30th.
DOJ WANTED IT DONE BY OCTOBER
17.
FOUND A MIDDLE THERE.
>> WE SPEAK ABOUT THE DOCUMENTS
AS IF THEY FIT INTO A NEAT PILE
OR ONE.
IS IT POSSIBLE THAT A DOCUMENTS
CAN BE BOTH COVERED BY EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE AND CLASS IF IED?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
THEORETICALLY, YES.
SAY THE PRESIDENT HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE ABOUT STRATEGY
RELATING TO A CERTAIN FOREIGN
COUNTRY AND WRITTEN UP IN A
MEMO.
THAT IS CLASSIFIED AND ARGUABLY
COVERED BY EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE,
TOO.
THE TRUMP TEAM SAYING IF THEY'RE
PRIVILEGED YOU CANNOT USE THEM
AGAINST US IN COURT.
>> THE DOJ WILL APPEAL.
HOW LONG WILL THAT TAKE?
>> DOJ FILED A NOTICE OF APPEAL.
WE ARE AT THE DISTRICT COURT
LEVEL IN FEDERAL COURT IN
FLORIDA.
THEY WILL APPEAL.
IF THEY APPEAL THEY GO TO THE
11th CIRCUIT COURT OF APPEALS
AND TAKES A LONG TIME.
IN THE MEANTIME WHAT DOJ HAS
SAID THEY'LL DO IS ASK FOR A
STAY WHICH IS BASICALLY ASKING
THE COURT OF APPEALS FOR A PAUSE
AND SPECIFIC CLI FOCUSED ON THE
100 CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
THIS IS OUT OF THE 11,000 TOTAL
SO TALKING ABOUT 1% OF DOCUMENTS
BUT THE MOST IMPORTANT.
SO THAT COULD HAPPEN MUCH MORE
QUICKLY.
AND THAT WILL GO TO THE SAME
COURT OF APPEALS.
WE COULD HAVE TWO SORT OF
PARALLEL TRACKS.
THE STAY TRACK AND THEN
IMPORTANT NOT ABOUT THE 11th
CIRCUIT.
ONE OF THE CONSERVATIVE COURTS
OF APPEALS IN THE COUNTRY.
SEVEN JUDGES ARE REPUBLICAN
APPOINTEES.
WITH SENIOR JUDGES FIVE MORE
REPUBLICAN NOMINATED.
FOUR DEMOCRATIC.
YOU GET THREE RANDOMLY CHOSEN AT
THE PANEL.
I RAN THIS BY MY BROTHER-IN-LAW
WHO IS A PHYSICS PhD.
I SAID WHAT'S THE ODDS?
HE SAID 65.5% TO HAVE TWO OR
MORE REPUBLICANS ON THE
THREE-JUDGE PANEL.
>> SHOUT OUT TO THE
BROTHER-IN-LAW PLAYING A ROLE
TODAY.
>> TALK ABOUT THE TIMELINE NOW.
HOW LONG WILL THIS PROCESS TAKE?
>> THE CALENDAR IS IMPORTANT.
THAT SEARCH HAPPENED AUGUST 8th,
MONDAY NIGHT.
WE ARE NOW BREAKING NEWS
SEPTEMBER 16.
WE ARE ALREADY ALMOST SIX WEEKS
OUT FROM THE SEARCH AND THE
SPECIAL MASTER HASN'T BEGUN.
MIDTERMS, NOVEMBER 8.
THE JUDGE GINN A DEADLINE OF
NOVEMBER 30.
THIS REVIEW WILL CARRY ON PAST
MIDTERMS.
ALSO DOJ'S NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO FULLY ACCESS THE DOCUMENTS
UNTIL THE REVIEW IS DONE.
INTO 2023.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS.
IN THE YEAR BEFORE A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION PEOPLE
START TO DECLARE.
IF DONALD TRUMP DECLARES COULD
ADD A COMPLICATION INT